17 octobre 2018 je cite en relation
étroite avec le président de la
République le Gouvernement a pris sa
décision nous abandonnons le projet
d'aéroport de Notre-Dame-des-Landes
cette déclaration est celle du Premier
ministre Édouard Philippe ce président
de la République c'était manuel Macron
ce jour-là l'État de droit a abdiqué ce
jour-là Emmanuel Macron a dit au
hors-la-loi que leur violence était plus
forte que les lois de la République ce
jour-là tous ceux qui refusent les
règles de notre démocratie on obtenu un
permis de cassé dans les Deux Sèvres 61
gendarmes blessés ont payé vos lâchetés
politiques d'hier mesurez-vous toute la
gravité de la situation mesurez-vous
qu'il s'agit d'une guérilla organisée
ultra violente méthodique politique
contre nos institutions mesurez-vous que
ces factieux
comme le nom seulement nos agriculteurs
notre ressources en ont mais surtout
notre modèle républicain et démocratique
les élus de la nation qui osent mêler
leurs écharpes tricolores assez casseurs
sont indignes de la fonction qu'ils
assument au nom de la République non
tout n'est pas permis c'est cagoulés ne
représentent en rien le peuple parce que
le peuple lui-même ne supporte plus que
le politique recule sans cesse quand il
s'agit de l'autorité de l'État faites
enfin courageusement de l'accès à l'eau
pour notre agriculture une priorité
nationale laisser ces héros de pacotille
de côté madame la Première ministre
Notre-Dame-des-Landes était une
reddition démocratique et politique vous
avez alors ouvert la porte au pire et
désormais vous ne contrôlez presque plus
rien quand on rétablirez-vous enfin des
limites infranchissables pour nos
agriculteurs notre démocratie et notre
République